so we talked last week about the repeal
of net neutrality net neutrality has
been repealed the net neutrality I call
them Internet freedom regulations that
were put in place under President Obama
but the structure for which actually
came from FCC Chairman Michael Powell
during the Republican George W Bush
administration we did not have these
oppressive
left-wing parameters for net neutrality
it was something that was actually
developed over the last couple of
administration's that was repealed we
knew this was probably going to happen
when Donald Trump initially appointed
Ajit PI a former Verizon lobbyist lawyer
rather what's the difference at this
point right to be chairman of the FCC
not exactly draining the swamp and we
knew that overwhelmingly Americans were
in favor of net neutrality it was the
internet service providers and the
lobbyists that were really against it
and one of the things that we knew would
be allowed if net neutrality were
repealed is that Internet service
providers would be legally allowed to
create Fast and Slow lanes on the
internet they'd be allowed to charge
more for better access to certain
portals or web sites and services and
all along during this debate Internet
service providers said don't worry we
would never do those things you can
trust us look at our web sites we have
pledges on our web sites about what we
will and won't do even if net neutrality
were repealed Comcast for example had
the following pledges and statements on
their corporate website before the
repeal of net neutrality started to be
talked about and you can verify what
we're putting up on the screen for you
by using the Wayback Machine online to
look at older versions of web pages
Comcast won't block access to lawful
content Comcast won't throttle back the
speed at which content comes to you
Comcast doesn't prioritize not won't
doesn't prioritize Internet traffic or
create paid fast lanes and then a couple
of other provisions that are less
relevant here as soon as a repeal of net
neutrality started to be discussed early
in the Trump administration all of a
sudden half of those pledges slash state
were removed and it was obvious what it
was that Comcast intended to do the new
version of Comcast pledges or quotes on
their website say merely we do not block
slowdown or discriminate against lawful
content we believe in full transparency
in our customer policies we are for
sustainable and legally enforceable net
neutrality protections for our customers
you'll notice that from this and we can
keep it up
gone is we won't throttle back speed at
which content comes to you gun is
Comcast doesn't prioritize Internet
traffic or create paid fast lanes note
the language there to begin with was
Comcast does not rather than com Comcast
pledges never - sure you didn't do that
when it was written in the law that you
weren't allowed to but of course any
reasonable person knows that Comcast and
other Internet service providers have
obviously been planning to bail on the
principles of net neutrality as soon as
legally possible which is now and I
actually saw people commenting online
okay if you don't like Comcast's new
policy use a different internet service
provider if you don't like that one
most people have no choice right this is
fundamentally a monopolistic market
where most people live in places where
you don't have a choice
you have one provider this is going to
be a disaster major protests are planned
but will that do anything and I know
people get mad at me Pat every time I
say this version of resistance or that
version of resistance won't do anything
David you're you're deflating these
activist movements I'm not trying to
deflate them but I also am trying to
think pragmatically about what will and
won't change this I believe that this is
an issue of voting that's the way to
change this you've got to vote them out
yeah I mean I mean some on the right are
now giving lip service to protecting net
neutrality we had that interview few
weeks ago with Andrew Torres on the
topic that's right is a path forward
here it's just not through the FCC and
and it's also not through anybody who
will be in the FCC when Donald Trump is
President of the United States so voting
is the path forward here and I actually
do get you know people can have
reasonable disagreements about
abortion right like I don't agree with
the anti-choice movement but I
understand based on what they consider
to be important moral and ethical values
how they might come away being against
abortion being legal I get that when it
comes to net neutrality there's no real
reason to be against it unless you've
just completely fallen for the talking
points of the Internet service providers
and their lobbyists yeah and with many
of the big issues of the day like say
abortion in gay marriage you may see
like a 50/50 split or a 60/40 split into
a population here it's an 80/20 split
there should not be a contest all you've
got is the people that are either for
personal reasons right they might just
have a vested interest in getting rid of
net neutrality maybe because of their
job or whatever the those suffering from
such significant cognitive dissonance
that they just believe whatever a GPI
and Comcast say and I don't know why you
would these are some of the worst ranked
companies when it comes to customer
satisfaction why would you ever take
their word for it or it's just you know
your Republican senator or congressman
said it so you're going or they don't
understand the issue well that's another
way yeah because when you look at when
you ask people are you for or against
net neutrality and then you ask them are
you for or against XY provision of net
neutrality overwhelmingly the provisions
get way higher favorability ratings than
net neutrality at large it's really bad
and I believe that all activism in favor
of net neutrality is good but I think
the path for words are really fixing
this is voting them out I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show quick break back after
this support for today's program comes
from health IQ who believes that the
best way to improve the health of the
world is to celebrate the health
conscious through social and financial
rewards so what they do is use science
and data to get you lower rates on life
insurance if you're a health conscious
person this includes runners and
cyclists and strength trainers and
people who eat healthy 56% of Health IQ
customers save between 4 and 33% on life
insurance and these are exclusive
savings to health IQ it's sort of like
saving money on your
car insurance for being a good driver
health IQ gets you lower rates on life
insurance for living a health-conscious
lifestyle after all physically active
people have a 34% lower risk of
all-cause mortality and a 56% lower risk
of heart disease to see if you qualify
get a free quote today at health iq.com
forward slash Pakman or mention the
promo code Pakman that's PA que ma n
when you talk to a health IQ agent
that's health iq.com /p a que ma n to
get your free quote